[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
We don't know because we that got lost
throughout time. Bible was created by
man. So how so if you if it's got lost,
we don't know. Then how do you know the
Bible isn't the end? Because it's
because it's you don't know who's
written it. When it comes to
interpreting the Quran in terms of all
the verses and everything, we just go
upon how the prophet interpreted it. how
the companions interpreted and how the
people that came after them interpreted
them. Yeah,
[Music]
I could I could coach you. I could coach
Look, the Quran the Quran says that that
they had the in Muhammad's time. The
Bible has been the injil. Today, that's
not the angel. How do you know? Because
we know. Yeah. So, we're we're
challenging Muslims to engage with the
topic here. Yeah. That the Quran
confirms the Bible. And so, usually
Muslims obviously think that the Bible's
corrupted, but the Quran says otherwise.
So, Yeah. So a good debate. Oh yeah, for
sure. For sure. The inje is not the
Bible and the Bible is not the So would
you say the in we don't know because we
that got lost throughout time. Bible was
created by man. So how so if you if it's
got lost we don't know then how do you
know the Bible isn't the angel?
Because it's because it's you don't know
who's written it. Well, you don't know
who wrote the angel either. No, we know
who wrote the angel. That's come from
God. I I thought the Bible you don't
know who it's come from. Here's my
thing, brother. Is that actual fact that
it came from? In actual fact, you know
that the Bible has been written by a
minimum of 40 unnamed person. Hold up.
We know their names. No, you don't.
Yeah, we got you don't even
tell me what Tell me what you know about
Mark. Oh, yeah. Easy. Uh, he was a
companion of Peter, companion of Paul.
Um, his full name is John Mark. Okay.
So, we got some information about it.
Tell me. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean I mean is is that all I
need? You are basing your salvation on
that. Would you be able to tell me about
Abu Abu Herrera? I can't tell you a lot
about it because I'm not a scholar. But
what I do know is that these things to
me make no sense that you are basing
your salvation. It's a double standard.
No, no, it's not a double standard. I
can find out. But you you can't you guys
don't know, brother. You don't have
spoken to many people. But you don't you
don't have Abu Herrera's first name.
Listen, I have spoken to many people and
nobody knows about Mark, Luke. I just
told you about Mark. No, you haven't.
All you said is that he knew him. Ma
Matthew was a tax collector. But you
don't know nothing about him. What's his
I do. I just told you. Was he married?
Did he have children? What does what
does that have to do with what he wrote?
That tells you about the character of
the person and his history. How does
Wait, my brother, cuz like for example,
just just for example, right, Muhammad's
parents, they were not believers, right?
Um, but does that affect who Muhammad is
just because his parents were Muslim? It
tells you about the character of the
person. That's why you check the lineage
of the person where they come from.
That's why I'm telling you know that how
you find out about a history of a
person, what do you do when someone says
to you go and find out about this
person? Do you just go to him? No, you
go to everybody around them as well.
Find out what the character is, how he
is, what he's like, everything. But with
Mark, Matthew, Luke, and these people,
you know nothing about them. But we do
the part. Secondly, you don't do the
same with Muhammad. Listen. Secondly,
where your as I said to you, your 40
unknown people. I gave you a few. No.
No. A few names is useless. Your own
your own scholars, Christian scholars
have said we know nothing about it.
That's not what they said. Like like for
for example, brother, if I were to ask
you who wrote Sir Abakar, what would you
say? Nobody wrote it. Yes, they did. Who
wrote it? Tell me. I don't know. That's
what I asked you. That's not Nobody. But
I'm telling you and you're saying no.
The whole Quran wrote the Quran. The
whole Quran has cut is the actual words
of Allah subhanaa. I understand that
belief my brother. I'm asking about the
the Quran that we have together here on
earth. Who wrote that? Who wrote the
Quran? You you see this is a very big
misconception of what other people make.
Okay. Who's written it is irrelevant
because the wording has come from Allah.
So I can say the same thing brother. I I
can say I can say who Matthew, Mark,
Luke, people But let me let me let this
up in the morning. No, this is important
and and I have said I've had a vision.
But no, but this is important. Muhammad
says the same thing. Muhammad went into
the cave and claimed to have gotten a
vision from Gabriel. There are other
eyewitnesses that have seen exactly
Gabriel and and it's the same with
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John's
testimony. You are getting going for
Hey, I I appreciate you though. God
bless you. Okay. Oh man. So, so, so, so
when it come to the Bible, it matters
who wrote it. But when I ask, okay, who
wrote Sarabakar? You see, who wrote it?
It doesn't matter because it's all from
God. Oh. Oh, okay. I can say the same
thing. It don't matter who Matthew,
Mark, Luke, John are because it all came
from God. Thanks for coming, man. You
have the Quran that literally says like
it's cere 43. It says, "Why do they come
to you, oh prophet, for judgment when
they have the Torah in which Allah's
judgments are in?" Right? And so we see
here that this is an example of that the
Torah is still um bearing upon them and
they still have to follow it. And if
they don't follow the Torah and the
judgments that Allah put in there,
they're hypocrites, right? And they
they'll be in wrong standing with Allah.
So what would your thoughts be on on
that? To be honest with you, I haven't
done much a lot of research into this.
The best thing for us, I mean, for me
personally, to obviously go home, do
some more research. But the best way to
kind of put it is um when it comes to
interpreting the Quran in terms of all
the verses and everything, we just go
upon how the prophet interpreted it, how
the companions interpreted it, and how
the people that came after them
interpreted it. And they tell us to
basically follow what the Quran says,
and anything that would contradict what
the Bible would say, then basically
Allah did not say that. So when it comes
to like for example what you have today
the Catholic Bible and the King James
Bible uh we don't believe that it was
preserved. We believe that it's been
changed over time and that's why we
don't actually so so this is like so I
yeah we so we know the the the that
narrative. It's like um for for me when
I read the Quran, brother, it's it's
tough to take that narrative and and I
see that in the Quran cuz the Quran
consistently talks in the 7th century,
right, in Muhammad's time, it talks
about how they um they had the Torah and
Injil with them, right? And how they're
supposed to judge by it and how they're
supposed to live by it and recite it
correctly. And so how the Quran's
confirming the Torah and with them and
this is in the seventh century. So, we
have those manuscripts like King James.
That's an English translation that comes
way later. I'm talking about the actual
Greek and Hebrew manuscripts that
existed at the time. And so, we have
those, right? Which is what the King
James is based off of. If you did you
have something you wanted to say on
that? I mean, you can correct me if I'm
wrong, but what I've kind of uh I've
done a bit of research, not a lot, but
I've came across that uh Jesus, he
didn't actually speak Greek or Hebrew. I
think I believe he spoke Aramaic. All of
it. So, Aramaic was his mother tongue.
That was his main tongue, but he spoke
Hebrew. He used to read uh the Hebrew
scrolls in the synagogue and then he
also used to communicate with the cent
the Roman centurions and the soldiers
and government. So he spoke Greek as
well. I'm not actually too sure about
that. Black and black. Once again, I
would have to go home and do some more
research on that. But based off what
I've read and what people have told me,
I know that he read Aramaic and I know
that the oldest manuscript we have of
the Bible itself, it's not in Aramaic. I
know that it's in Greek. I believe it's
called something like the Codex or
something like that. And the size of it
is very very small. And I know that for
example, no, no, just just real quick.
Yeah. Yeah. So the Codex Anaticus, it's
like a it's the earliest completed um I
guess Bible that we found with with all
of the books together. Yeah. But before
that, we have manuscripts of different
books um fragments um like uh the the
Jon I forgot how to say it. But but
anyway, it's one of those the one you're
talking about that's small like a credit
card. Yeah. That that's um one of the
the manuscripts of John. Um, but the
Codex is it's all the books together
that are it's the first full uh earliest
one that we found, but there's ones that
exist but like before that. Um, so with
that being said, Jesus speaking Aramaic,
Hebrew, and Greek um I I don't think
that that's a problem with if his word
let's say let's just grant that he only
spoke Aramaic um and the New Testament
or the Gospel is written in Greek. I
don't think that that would have a
bearing on recording his words, right?
Because even in like for example the
Quran records Jesus's words in Arabic
but Jesus didn't speak Arabic you know
so I don't think that that's should be
an issue. So when it comes to the Quran
it's not basically the sayings of people
rather it is the literal verbatim word
of God. So that's that's the argument
not argument that's the that's the point
that we would make that uh because the
Quran is is the literal words of God it
cannot be um it cannot there cannot be
any mistakes in it. For example, the
words of man because we're men. We make
mistakes. There will be mistakes in it.
So that's why we would take the words of
God over the words of man. What what do
you think about the parts where it's
quoting men, right? Like cuz it says
Jesus said and then
so Jesus said so for example like in
Arabic like he said. So is basically
what Allah said like this is Allah is
saying like his literal is literal words
of God. Okay. So when the prophet was
when he is saying something, he is
basically saying what Allah told him.
He's not saying anything else extra.
Right. Right. Yeah. So, so it's it's
Allah is basically telling Muhammad and
Muhammad is obviously repeating it word
for word verbatim. Um and so Allah tells
him what Jesus said before, right? And
so so that that is a theological view,
right? And which is fair as a Muslim to
have. Uh I'm just saying to be to have a
consistent argument. Sorry. Just give me
one more just
then. We have to go. We are waiting for
someone. Yeah, for sure. For sure.
Right. Go ahead. Sorry. For sure. Um, so
when Allah records Jesus's words in
Arabic, um, you know, obviously Jesus
didn't speak Arabic, but it's recording
his words in Arabic. And so that
shouldn't it shouldn't be a problem if
Jesus's words are recorded in Hebrew or
if it's recorded in Greek, you know, uh,
it's just recording his words, right?
Yeah. Is that fair? Um, so you're saying
that it doesn't matter whether Jesus's
words were recorded in a different
language from the language that he
spoke. Is that what you're saying? Yes.
Okay. It could still be a revelation.
You know, exactly. So you know the
manuscripts that you're referring to,
but obviously test the testimonies from
people from from men go. Same thing with
the Muhammad. I mean the Quran. The
Quran is actually the verb of the words
of God though. But it's it's the
recitation of of men. Like you you have
like Yeah. Yeah. So when it comes to the
Quran Yeah. Um you have the angel
Gabriel who comes down and who gives the
literal words of God to prophet Muhammad
wasam. So this is what we would believe
about like the the authors of the
gospel. We believe that they're inspired
by the Holy Spirit that God sent his
holy spirit to empower them and and and
speak and write down even from their
perspective. Okay. You know that that's
what we believe with the uh the author
of Okay, that's fair. I mean I mean you
can correct me if I'm wrong, but Sure.
You can say go ahead. I know that there
may be some sort of like uh
contradictions or like mistakes in the
Bible in terms of like numeric
contradictions. Perhaps you could uh
Sure. So like obviously we don't like we
have a different belief when it comes to
preservation. Okay. Right. Like you
believe as you just said that you know
you believe that the Quran is word for
word letter for letter the words of
Allah. Right. And obviously we as
Christians we believe that yeah God
inspired men to write. So um even though
the message and theme is is godly, it's
from straight from God, them writing,
they can make a mistake in writing like
a copist error or something like that.
So when you see numerical mistakes like
in Old Testament manuscripts and you can
compare them to the manuscript and see
where the copious error is, there's
copious errors or people um um repeat
lines or miss misspell or you know we we
there's there's things like that. I
understand you know I mean when it comes
to that like um in terms of numerical
contradictions we believe that God he
because he's perfect and he was all no
he doesn't really make those mistakes
whereas like you said uh in terms of uh
Luke John Mark Matthew they were
inspired by God right so although they
were inspired by God they still made
mistakes so I would say that the prophet
Muhammad is not on the same standard as
uh Matthew Luke John would you say that
there's a difference between the actual
message that God gives versus the the
writing of it it being written down. So
we need to know if it actually is the
message of God. So we talk about for
example has it been preserved. So we
know for like for us Muslims we we all
kind of come to an agreement where the
Quran is something that can be memorized
literal word for word. It depends on
which one you're talking about. We're
talking about the the Quran that's what
that's all Muslims kind of agree upon.
the standardized Quran by uh the
companions for example man but again
like you he even had disagreements back
then on on that so that's a good point
so when it came to the the compilation
of the Quran during his time he had the
companions who came together as a
consensus so they all agreed upon it at
the time they didn't they did look like
for example yeah go ahead um what's the
what's the brother's name um it's
slipping my mind right now but he uh he
was one of the people that Muhammad said
you should learn the Quran from okay Um
there's Umar Katab and then there's
uh what is his name? It's slipping me.
Uh
but I can't remember but it's it's
slipping my mind right now. However, um
he he didn't agree with Uman's order to
collect for everybody to turn their
Qurans in. And he also didn't agree for
people to be following like Zade bin
Thab. He's like I know more than Zin
Tab. was reciting it when he was little,
you know, why should I follow them? And
everybody knows that and nobody, you
know, refuted him on that. And so he and
he told people to hide their Qurans when
Uman gave the order to collect them so
they can rewrite it. And so we see early
on there's like that that disagreement
of of that. I mean there are there were
many many narrations of disagreements
between for example the major companion
Abu Baka and
they did obviously came to you know they
sorted out the differences but when it
came to the Quran compilation I have
actually I have not personally come
across that thing that you were talking
about perhaps I can go home and do more
research yeahbas
there it is ib mass my goodness yeah so
ib mass yeah so there there's an
authentic that's sahi too by the way and
yeah so you'll you'll find where he's he
tells them to basically hide the Quran
and keep them from from Usman and stuff
like that. I'll definitely look into
that. Well, thank you for sharing that.
Yeah, for sure. We have to go next week.
No, it was it was a pleasure. Yeah, it
was a pleasure talking to you guys. Take
care, guys. Take care. Take care. Thank
you. Thank you. Yeah. So, just to do a
little quick wrap up here, man. Um
talking about the preservation and
obviously, yeah, you know, we have a
different idea of what preservation is.
And I think that the Islamic view of
preservation, it doesn't hold up. it
can't hold up because you have spelling
mistake, you have words missing, you
have different Qurans out there and so
by their standard as as he looks into
this by their standard he's going to
have to say that the Quran hasn't been
preserved if that's his standard. So,
um, it's going to be tough. You guys
look into it. Hops, wash, koon, duri,
uh, shoot, kabir, uh, casai. Look into
it. Telling you. Um,
and then on top of that, obviously, the
Quran says that the Bible's been
preserved. So, how do you go against
Allah with that?
Ow. It's not the Bible today. So, then
what do we have? It's not the Bible
today. What do we have? In is not the
Bible today. I I'll walk with you,
brother. I'll walk with you. I know it's
all right. Like so so the Quran says
that we have the angel with us you know
chapter 5:47 the Bible today is not the
angel man why do you say that it's not
it's not how do you know it is not it's
been changed man how do you how do you
know because there's I can go into it
which I haven't got time but there's a
lot of things
I got you in in the short time that we
have right if the if the angel's been
changed if the gospel's been changed
then that means that that means that
Allah is is he's confirming a changed
book you know No, no, no, no. So, when
do you think it was changed? No, that
don't make sense. When do you think it
was changed? The Bible Uhhuh. which you
see today? Yeah. Is not is not that
that's not the that's not the same
scripture which was revealed to the
prophet Isa. So, what do they have then?
Sorry. What What was the angel that they
had in Muhammad's tongue? Cuz it says
they had it. Yeah, but not that. How do
you know? I know. How? Look to the
historians, man. Yeah, the historians
tell me it's it's the same. It's not,
man. It's not like Look, I'm just Look
into it, man. Look into it. I did. This
is what I'm saying. I'll leave you with
this. I can't quote you. I can't quote
you anything right now. I can I can I
can quote you the I can quot Look, the
Quran The Quran says that that they had
the in Muhammad's time. The Bible has
been Yeah. The Injilh today. That's not
the angel. How do you know? Because we
know. Okay. So, let me tell you how I
know it is. Okay. How we know it is is
that one, they had it written down in
Muhammad's time. We have those
manuscripts that were there, you know,
and so since we have those manuscripts,
you rely on manuscripts. Yeah, you do.
You don't rely on manuscripts for
transmission. We got a train of
narration which goes all the way back.
Yeah, but the Quran says don't rely on
manus. You do. You have a a Quran you
believe is written. All right, you guys.
You too, bro. Hey, thanks for this,
brother. Y'all take care. Be safe. Now,
this this is it. Just this is important.
All of a sudden, we don't rely on
manuscripts and transmission. Yes, you
do. Are you kidding me? You know how
many Muslims tell me we have the Quran
that goes all the way back to Muhammad,
the Birmingham manuscript, the the the
Sun manuscript, the Umaric manuscript.
Are you kidding me? you guys literally
are uh basing your claims on on
manuscripts that you guys think are
early enough to go back to Muhammad's
time yet all of a sudden. So when we say
okay we have early manuscripts in the
Gospels that go to Muhammad's time and
before all of a sudden it doesn't
matter. How does that not matter all of
a sudden? The double standard in Islam
is crazy guys. So yes, the Quran
confirms the Bible. When they say it's
changed and we say how do you know? They
have no answers. They say the Injil is
not the Bible we have today. How do you
know? They don't have any answers. So,
either I'm going to believe Allah or
should I believe the the Muslims of
today? I think I'm going to stick with
Allah and the Quran. If I'm going to be
a good Christian, I have to believe that
I have the gospel today and that it's
the truth. And if it's the truth, then
the Quran lied.
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.